GBBO.S08E10.The.Final.srt
In the beginning...
Look at that.
I love you, Flo.  I love you too now.
..there were 12.
Ohhhh!
Oh, pum, pum, pum, pum...
It's all right, I'll just hold it
like this.
Chin up.  I'm going.
No, you're not!
Now...
Keep calm.
Keep the nerves under control.  Yeah.
..there are three.
Not very happy with the ciabatta.
Oh... No pressure.
HE EXHALES
HE EXHALES AGAIN
BIRDSONG
Three remaining bakers.
Breathe in.
Breathe in for the apron.
Three final challenges.
From the beginning,
Steven seemed unstoppable.
You wouldn't think that wasn't
bread.
But his ingenious designs...
That is ridiculous.
..haven't always been matched
with great flavours.
Overall, it's a bit bland.
But the three-time Star Baker fought
his way to the final.
I've ticked every box.
Handshakes, Star Bakers.
There's that huge box
that needs one big tick in it.
The winner.
Kate's road to the final has been
rocky.
SHE GASPS
So nearly worked, didn't it?
But her creativity...
I love that octopus.
..historic inspiration...
I researched into the recipes
onboard the Titanic.
..and her bold flavours...
The mango with the curry just works.
Very clever.
..ensured a steady rise.
The cake is sensational.
I do want to win but I'm not going
to be arrogant enough to think
the other two bakers in there
aren't fantastic.
Through the outset, Sophie has
marched through the challenges with
military precision.
Oh!  That's delicious.
But for the two-time Star Baker,
there's one enemy
that threatened defeat.
Bread, bread, bread, bread!
The dough's quite underdone.
I hate bread.
The apples don't
really look that green.
It's a dark art
that I'm yet to master.
We never thought I'd get this far.
It's just like a big thumbs-up.
Yes, this is what you're meant to
do.
Morning, bakers,
many congratulations on making it
through to the Bake Off final.
Now, for your final
Signature Challenge,
Paul and Prue would like you to bake
a batch of 12 small loaves.
But obviously they're not going to
make it that easy for you.
No, they want you to make
three different types of bread,
so four of your loaves need to be
intricately shaped, so I don't know,
plaited, for example.
Four need to be flavoured,
and four need to be made with
an alternative grain such as spelt
or buckwheat. You've got three hours
to make 12 small loaves.
On your mark...  Get set...
Bake!
Good luck, guys.
This is the final. I woke up
this morning so excited.
Whoever wins, it'll be amazing.
The Signature is something
I particularly love.
Bread. We've asked the bakers to
produce 12 loaves.
Three different types.
Different baking times,
different proving time.
It would be very easy to get into
a muddle.
It's critical to remain calm,
be absolutely confident
about what you're doing
and create baking magic.
Hello, Sophie.  Hello, Sophie.  Good
morning. How are you?  Finals day.
Yes.  Excited?  Nervous, yup.
Sophie's attempting
round spelt loaves,
ciabattas flavoured with
wild mushrooms,
and plaited brioche
flavoured with orange.
You've picked two breads
that take a long time to make.
Brioche, technically overnight.
Ciabatta, a long prove.
Yep, because I thought
that was a great idea.
Not really realising that I'd
stitched myself up a little bit.
Yeah.  You'll be more impressed,
though, if she pulls it off, right?
Exactly.
You will have shown three skills,
never mind all the others,
shaping and flavouring.
It's the final, you've got to go
for it.  Got to go for it.
Kate is playing this final Signature
a little safer.
I'm keeping the doughs quite simple,
and just want a good bake on it.
She'll shape her simple white dough
into flowers,
and she's also making spelt loaves,
and a flavoured loaf
filled with curry,
sweetened with yet another
one of her discoveries.
Jaggery gur?  Bit of jaggery.
Do you want to try some?  Yeah.
It's basically a sugar.
Like a cane sugar type thing?
Yeah.
SHE COUGHS
Wow. My whole body's perked up.
That's fanta...
What a lovely flavour.
I kind of got into jaggery when I
found it in, like, this little shop
back home in Liverpool
on Bold Street.
Do you just go round shops trying
to find things nobody's heard of to
cook with?  Yeah.
Rummaging in the back
of the supermarket shelves.
Ah! Here's a thing!
NOEL: Whilst Kate and Steven's first
doughs are ready for proving...
That's going to go for an hour.
..Sophie's brioche is already
proving time-consuming.
Enriching the dough
and it's a lot of butter.
A lot of butter!
Right, er...
For his second flavoured dough...
Baked garlic.
..Steven isn't holding back.
I'm going to whole-roast
these garlic,
and you'd think three bulbs
in four loaves is a lot,
but it just becomes a really sweet,
mellow flavour and it's really good.
Steven's making flavoured loaves
with garlic, rosemary,
and fontina cheese.
He's also making spelt and rye
loaves, and his shaped loaves,
filled with chocolate and cinnamon,
have been inspired
by his boyhood hobbies.
The shaped one is going to be a
Winston knot.
A what?  A Winston knot.  What's that?
I think it's a tie knot, isn't it?
It's got three strands to it,
hasn't it?  Yes.
I remember doing knots when I was
in Scouts just because I wanted to
get that badge.
Channelling your childhood.
I did get my badge. And for baking.
Steven began baking long before
he joined the Scouts.
Did you cut your own hair?
I think I might have let
my friend do it.
Steven and I both share
a passion for cooking.
He was always clearing up after me
in the kitchen.
I don't think my mum realises
just how much she influences him
and how much she helps him,
how much of a guide she is to him.
I think my mum would be quite
surprised to...to realise
that a lot of this is
to do with her.
I am immensely proud.
He's my Star Baker.
That is flavoured dough.
The more doughs
the bakers complete...
That's going to go down
for an hour.
..the more complicated this final
Signature Bake becomes.
You leave it in this
until it's about doubled in size.
Each dough will have
a different proving time,
and it gets harder.
They'll need to budget enough
remaining time for a second prove,
then the baking itself.
The second prove will vary depending
on how well they've done.
And if nine variable timings
wasn't enough to contend with...
I'm to do number three.
..all three finalists are attempting
a dough using spelt flour.
I'm doing this one by hand because
it's very easy to overwork spelt.
You just end up with a chewing gum.
How's that doing?
This is spelt and rye.
It's the same stuff the Roman Army
would've eaten with olive oil.
Obviously I'm going to do
something historic, aren't I?
And I'm obsessed.
My favourite film's Gladiator.
So I've got a running joke
with my dad about that.
There you are, Kate,
by the Pyramids.
Growing up, she was into
many different things.
It started with dance school, drama.
Fishing, doing her martial arts.
Horse riding.
Brownies.
Go-karting.
Then she started baking.
Even practising for the Bake Off
hasn't slowed Kate down.
Katie is doing a Masters degree in
occupational health and safety, as
well as doing her full-time job, as
well as practising all the recipes.
I remember the phone call to say,
"Dad, I'm going to be on Bake Off."
And I was really a bit choked.
The next minute she'd actually
got a place in the final.
It's just amazing. It really is.
As well as three doughs with
three different proving times...
I'm just going to go
get another timer.
..Kate's given herself something
else to keep track of.
This is for the inside
of my flavoured breads.
Like a peshwari filling.
So I'm just putting some jaggery in
now, which will just sweeten it up.
And she's not the only one
spending time on a filling.
I don't know what they'll think of
wild mushroom ciabatta. I like it.
That's all that matters.
Is that your christening?
That is my christening.
She's always been very determined,
yes.
Even as a little girl.
She did like to bake
her own big cakes.
The ballet school. I think she would
have carried on with the ballet,
but she just got too tall.
The army was
the most surprising one.
When she puts her heart into
something, she goes and gets it.
Very proud of Sophie,
I've always been proud of Sophie.
Sophie did not apply for Bake Off,
I applied. I put it in for her.
I'm incredibly proud of Sophie.
To come up with some of the stuff
she's done is quite amazing.
Absolutely incredible.
If I heard Sophie's name being
called out and she's been crowned
best baker in Britain,
even from an Irish perspective!
You got to the end
and you might win!
Well...  You'd be famous.
Can't go to Tesco's
in my pyjamas any more.
You just want to get bread
over with, don't you?
Yeah, and do you know what, that's
not really the feeling I should have
on finals, but I know I'm not
great at it, so it's kind of like,
let's just get it over and done
with.  Get that one done.  Yeah.
Bakers, we are halfway through
your final Signature Challenge.
Anyone need anything?
You warm enough?
Current tent temperature.
I've had bad experiences
with this proving drawer.
Best just to stay clear of it.
It's had half an hour.  Now the maths
gets even more complicated.
Yeah, I've got about 15 minutes
until I make the Winston knot.
No, I've got two minutes
until I make the Winston knot
and 15 minutes in which to do them.
The judges will expect loaves that
are uniform in size and shape.
I'm just bread-measuring.
I think we should give them Roman
soldier names cos this is what
the Roman Army used to eat.
Yeah.  So that's Maximus.
Maximus.  Decimus, Aurelius,
and, erm...
Stuart?  Stuart.
But every minute spent weighing
and shaping...
These two get crossed over.
..is a minute they won't have
for a second prove and baking.
Apparently it's like a French sort
of design.
It's a bit different to, like,
the traditional knot shape.
You'd think it would be easy to get
things to look the same but it's
not. I'm glad I went to Scouts.
I'm not sure it did much
for my knot-making skills.
That is now going to prove again.
I'm just going to give them,
like, 20 minutes.
I have to get it in there.
That's cinnamon sugar
and chocolate chips.
Weighing out my ciabatta so it can
go on for its second prove.
This is called a couche, which is
French for "bed", and it just gives
the dough a little bit of support
while it's rising.
I'm putting it to bed.
Once upon a time
in the Bake Off tent...
there was a girl who was terrible
at making bread.
There's a kind of a knot
used in nautical,
it's called a monkey's fist.
And that looks exactly the same.
You're going to miss me.  Terribly.
There's just 45 minutes remaining
in the final Signature Challenge.
I'd really like to give it
a long time to second prove,
but I'd rather it be baked in the
oven, so I need to get them in.
We're running out of time,
they've got to go in, ready or not.
This is the flavoured dough.
It's only going to get
a little bit of a prove.
Right, I need to get a wriggle
on now.
That was a bit of a balls-up one.
HE TUTS AND SIGHS
I'm starting them off quite high
temperature, they'll get a nice
crust on them,
and then I'll drop it down.
I wanted to give them
another 15 minutes' proving,
but I would rather they were baked.
Bakers, you only have half an hour
left.
Not the best they've looked,
but also not the worst.
I don't think I'm going to have
enough oven space, so what I'm going
to have to do is move these
all onto one baking sheet.
Right, let's get these babies
in the oven.
These actually have puffed up
quite quickly.
These are my spelt loaves.
I'm scoring them cos as they rise,
if I didn't, they'd burst out
at the weakest point,
which is usually on the bottom.
That's annoyingly misshapen.
It's really not enough space.
That's everything in now,
by the skin of my teeth,
so hopefully they won't be
underbaked.
One has split horribly
in the middle.
Probably in my haste to get them
in the oven.
Ah! No pressure!
I'm concerned there won't be enough
air bubbles in my ciabatta,
but I'm afraid my spelt will be
like bricks.
SHE LAUGHS
I feel I want to do
one of those yoga poses.
Oh, oh, actually...
Oh!
SHE LAUGHS
What's happening in there?
My loaf has split.
That's OK, though, isn't it?
It's not the end of the world,
it's just irritating.
Mmm. Imagine if it was the end of
the world.
Your loaf split
and everything went...  Phoar!
Should have got them in sooner.
I'm going to whip them out
with about one minute to go.
Well, hopefully the taste will carry
me a little bit.
How long have we got left?
Just one minute remaining.
I really don't want to
drop any of these
because that would just be horrific.
This is what happens when you rush.
Ah!
Oh... Ah!
God, they've all split open.
Bakers, your time is up!
Not very happy with the ciabatta.
Oh, God, everyone's looks beautiful.
It's judgment time in the final
Signature Challenge.
Hello, Sophie.  Hi. How are you
doing?  Hello, Sophie.  Hello.
I think they look very good.
I do like the plait. It's a little
bit under proved but not much.
The naan bread looks interesting.
I wouldn't call that a ciabatta
really.
Well, let's see how it tastes.
I must say that I'm impressed by the
look of them,
especially the spelt ones.
It looks really good.
It sounds good.  It is slightly under
proved.
And, therefore, what follows is it's
slightly under baked.
I tell you what, the flavour is
lovely.
Mm.  Really nice flavour.
Great flavour.  Spelt is not the
tastiest.
That's a good start.  Let's look at
this ciabatta, shall we?
I always cut ciabattas this way
because you get more of an
indication of the overall structure.
A pretty nice structure but not
as open as it could be.
Smells really mushroomy.
They were dried mushrooms, weren't
they?  Uh, some dried, some sauteed.
It works. It brings you two
different textures in.
And they do taste very, very good.
I wouldn't call it a ciabatta
though.
Right, let's have a look at this.
Great structure. Great.
Look at that.  And, you know, the
orange really works.
I didn't think it would.  Excellent
flavour.
Soft crumb. Great texture on the
outside and the plaiting is very
good as well. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hmm. They definitely do look a
little different, don't they?
Yes.  That one does not look much
like that one.
They do look pretty terrible.
We're looking for consistency.
They do look awful.  So,
the bread has the garlic running
through it and then there's some
cheese and rosemary in the centre.
Smells good.
It's actually a little disappointing
because it's quite tough.
Your dough needed more water.
OK.  Dry dough will split wherever it
wants to go and that's what's caused
that and that to be totally
different.
Yeah.  These don't look good either.
It's massively under proved.
Rye bread tends to rip.
Yeah.
Look at that one there.
I agree with it trying to pull away.
It instantly means that you've under
proved it.  Yeah.  But let's have a
taste.
It's probably going to be slightly
doughy inside.
And it tastes like
that. It's gluey in your mouth.
Nice flavour, though.  Beautiful
flavour.
Just right, the rye and the spelt.
The knots.  They are so artisan
and real and beautiful.
It's always tricky when you put
something into the middle.
Does it destroy the crumb?
And I think you've done quite well
on the sweet one there.
That is very good.
It's delicious. I think the
chocolate's really good and you've
got just enough cinnamon. It's not
overpowering.
Under proved, under proved, perfect.
Thank you very much, Steve.  Thank
you.  Thank you.
I must say, I think these are
interesting and they look absolutely
beautiful.  Now, this is the spelt.
Yeah.  It's got a little rip but a
nice neat pattern.
I'm not going to quarrel with the
actual flavour,
except that I think if you'd had a
little salt in there you'd have
enhanced it.  Uh, I quite like it.
You push it, it springs back,
which is a good sign.
Let's have a look at these. Nice.
That's the sound I like to hear.
Great structure. You can tell, you
see where the knife drags the dough,
doesn't cut through like a cake,
it's pulling so you have this
tension there.
I think the texture's perfect.
Nice and crisp on the outside.
I'm getting a little bit of flavour
in there as well, which is good.
OK.  That's a good one.  All right,
now, let's look at these ones.
It's the filled one, isn't it?  Yeah.
Oh, no.  Are you all right?
What's he thinking?  You can never
tell.
I'll tell you what I think. I think
it's got a lovely texture.
I think it's properly baked.
I like the curry and I like the
flaky edge.
It tastes divine. The structure's
spot on.
I like the filling. Something I
might even look at.
I think overall you've done very
well.
Well done, Kate.  Thanks.
It was much better than I expected.
Woo. Woop-woop.
SHE LAUGHS
Yeah... Ah... I mean...
Mm...
I did it as well as I could have
done in the time.
I thought bread was going to be my
undoing and it's nice to know I'm
not starting from behind.
I am frustrated with myself.
But then I think, "What's the point,
it's not going to change anything?"
Now the finalists face mastering not
one but two levels
of absolute baking precision.
Time for your final Technical
Challenge,
which today has been set for you by
Prue.
Prue, have you been kind to the
finalists? No.
It's all about the bake.
No trouble.  It's all about the bake.
As ever the technical will be judged
blind so I'm going to have to ask
you crazy kids to skedaddle.
Off you go. For your final Technical
Challenge Prue would like you to
make ten ginger biscuits baked to
perfection with a powerful snap.
Prue wants half of them to be oval
and the other half to be square.
But they all need to be intricately
iced.
You have two and a half hours.
On your marks.  Get set.
Bake.
The finalists all have
identical ingredients...
and Prue's pared down recipe.
It seems quite straightforward,
which worries me.
Some lace pattern does look
complicated.
This is the Bake Off final,
and what could be more of a classic
British bake than a ginger biscuit?
They are exquisite.
It's all royal icing.
As we've said it must be exactly
these decorations.
They should be able to look at that
and know that they should first pipe
the outline and then flood it.
Of course, you'll need a thicker
icing for the baubles than you need
for the flooding. Although the icing
is very intricate and difficult to
do we want a really crisp perfect
biscuit.
Beautiful.  So we are looking for a
really nice snap with these
biscuits, aren't we?  It should make
a crack.
I love the fact that you're dunking.
I'm too posh to dunk.
Are you?  You didn't see.  You're
never too posh to dunk.
You're dead right.
It just says make the ginger
biscuits using the creamer method.
After this morning I'd like to do
much better
into this afternoon's technical.
It's a bit hard to get
tablespoons of beaten egg.
One, two. I'm expecting that to be
quite a stiff dough.
I've done it wrong.
I've put too much egg in.
I was focusing so much on the
muscovado that I
put too much egg
in. Awkward.
Right, try again.
After each stage they need to be
frozen.
It's quite a wet dough.
I expect it will firm up when it
gets in the fridge.
There is no indication of thickness.
I'll just go for a couple of
millimetres.
You want them nice and thin.
How's it going to fit?
It's not going to fit.
Kate's done it wrong again.
This isn't ideal. This is human
error in action.
Two hours remaining in the final
Technical Challenge.
Make eight by eight square templates
and a ten by seven oval.
This is not ten by seven.
So I'm going to have to freehand.
Ovals freehand, I'm assuming,
which'll be unamusing.
I've never drawn an oval before in
my life.
I do feel I'm back at, like, a
school art class.
Not very ovaly. That's annoying me.
Yeah, that's probably close enough.
So yours is more like a sort of,
uh...  Don't, no, no...
No?  I was going to say egg.
Don't say egg.  It's a little egg
like.
It looks like
something From Mork & Mindy travels
in.  I used to love that show.  I just
want to make sure I can get five.
So, one, two...  Three...
Idiot!
It needs to be quite a lot bigger.
I'm just going to freeze those and
then stick them in the oven.
They shouldn't take that long to
bake.
I'm going to cut them out afterwards
because I don't want the outsides to
burn. All about finesse.
Bakers, you are halfway through your
ginger biscuits.
Let's get these in the oven.  It
doesn't even say how long to bake
the biscuits for.  Just this bake.
So, I'm going for seven minutes and
check them thereafter.
Eight minutes, that sounds about
right.
I'm doing it at five minutes, I will
keep an eye on it, though.
It's all about the bake.
Prue said, you know, all about the
bake.  It's all about the bake.
This is royal icing.
Icing sugar, egg whites and lemon
juice.
Alls I can taste is just sweet air.
Trying not to mix it too hard
because the icing sugar will get
away with me.  Right, that's five
minutes.
Hm. I can see them browning around
the edge.
This is how I normally do it because
I just didn't want the edges to
burn.
I'm tempted to put them back in
actually for a couple more minutes.
I'm going to put the squares back
in. They just feel a little softer.
I'm going to get them back in the
oven.
Hm.
Just doing them in increments of two
minutes just to see how they look.
It needs a little bit longer because
they've got to have a nice snap to
them.
I think I'm happy with those.
They're nice and thin. They smell
good.
A couple more minutes. Just take a
minute.
They've just spread a little bit.
I didn't freeze them long enough.
Ah, snap.
Put them back in for a little flash
of, like, a minute.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
How much time is that per biscuit?
Six.  Minutes.
Six minutes.
Which one's the minutes again?
Go away. Go on.
Pipe flower pattern onto the oval
and pipe lace onto the square.
Simple, right?  Let's give it a go.
A bit too dark.
I burnt my biccies.
I hate rushing decorating.
Definitely the fastest I've ever
iced.  Is it enjoyable?
SHE MUMBLES
At home it
took me all day to ice 12 biscuits.
You've got four and a half minutes
per biscuit left.  Right.  Yeah.  OK.
I'm just thinking they're looking...
They're lovely, they look beautiful,
they're a little on the plain
side.
I'm having two different
consistencies
for piping and for flooding.
A lot more to do than perhaps I
first thought.
No time to redo anything.
There's so much intricate detail on
here.
If I can just get some basics done
on these.
Draw the line and then it kind of
semi-sets.
Flood the white icing and then pipe
the flower straight on top.
I should have just done that in
hindsight but I decided to flood ice
everything.  What I'm going to do is
do the same on each one and then go
back and add detail.
I think everyone's got their own
technique for flood icing, though.
If I run out of time, just have to
serve them, won't I?
My hand is surprisingly steady
actually considering
how nervous I am.
I think everybody needs to learn how
to speed pipe.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
Just not enough time at all.
If I can just get as much done on
these coloured ones.
I'm just going to pipe some dots
around the flooded ones.
I literally can't give you eye
contact right now unless you're a
biscuit and you need some icing on
you.
I mean, look how many biscuits are
uniced.
Do you want me to do one for you?
No.
I haven't actually taken more than
about three breaths in the last two
minutes.  I haven't breathed.
I haven't looked up. They're looking
increasingly messier.
It's actually really hard going on
your hand.
Oh!  My back's killing me.
Bakers, time is up.
Step away from your nozzles.
They look good, mate.  Have you both
finished?
Prue and Paul are expecting ten
exquisitely delicious
ginger biscuits with
a perfect snap, and they'll have no
idea whose is whose.
Shall we start with this one then,
Prue?
They're beautifully even.
Likewise with the oval.
There has been flooding.
The icing is nice and thin.
It could have been a little bit
thinner in order to flood it better
because this is a bit lumpy.
That went snap.  It did.
Nice and crisp.
That is a very good ginger biscuit.
Lovely flavour.  There's a couple of
issues with this one.
One, they're not finished. Two,
they're very different.
They aren't the same as that.
No.  But they might be redeemed by
the bake. Nice crunch.  Mm.
It's a bit dark, that one, actually.
Tastes good.  Texture is beautiful.
Yeah, but the problem is, look,
there's nothing on them.
These are quite neat, actually.
Mm-hm.  Uh, they're quite big, you
know, the blobs on them.
Yeah.  But they are finished. The
biscuits aren't very square.
They've spread a tiny bit in the
oven but this still looks really
good biscuit.  Yeah. Nice snap.
Flavour's very good, texture's very
good.
Let's have a look at the other ones.
It's flooded well, this.
I just think it's lost something.
The piping here is not blobs.
If the icing had been a bit thicker
you would have got that perfect
bobbly edge.
But who has triumphed in the
last Technical Challenge?
This is third place.
Oh, what a surprise.
Well, Kate, you know you didn't
finish.
Yeah.
Second place...
..is this one.
The consistency of the icing was
slightly off and some of your
biscuits
were slightly round. But they were
all finished, so well done.
That leaves Steven in first place.
Steven, the icing isn't perfect.
No.  But it is more intricate and you
have tried hard to get the shape.
It's a really good crack at a nice
biscuit.  Thank you.
Oh! I was willing that. I was
willing that to happen.
There is a chance but everything
tomorrow's going to have to be bang
on.
Fair enough, came third, didn't
finish them.
I mean, I had a good bake on the
bread and going into the Showstopper
I think everyone's going to be
starting from roughly the same
point.
Just one challenge remains
in this year's competition.
In just a few hours,
at a very special garden party for
family and friends we'll discover
the winner of
The Great British Bake Off.
Coming into today,
I think what we've got is two
challenges that turn everything
upside down.
Initially, we'd put Kate on top,
close to Sophie and then Steven.
The technical was then Steven,
Sophie and Kate.
So it is literally reversed.
The fact of the matter is, whoever
wins the Showstopper is going to be
the winner.  What happens if they're
all even at the end of
the Showstopper?  I'm walking out.
You win, Noel.
Do I?  Yes.  Amazing.
Morning, bakers. Welcome to the last
ever Bake Off challenge before one
of you is named champion of 2017.
For your final Showstopper,
Paul and Prue would love you to make
a large entremet.
As we all know, an entremet is
a thing that Sandi knows about.
An entremet is a light, delicate,
multi-layered cake that was
originally served as a dessert
between courses.  Your entremet must
have a minimum of five elements,
one of which must be sponge.
The entire cake should be covered in
perhaps a glaze.
Or maybe a ganache, whichever you
choose,
your entremet should be decorated to
the highest of standards.
And, when sliced, should hold
together perfectly with each of the
delicate layers clearly visible.
You have five hours.
BOTH:  On your marks, get set, bake!
This is the most unforgiving final
Showstopper in Bake Off history.
A perfect entremet is a flawlessly
decorated mousse cake,
filled with distinct, delicate
layers,
delivering contrasting textures and
complementary flavours.
The three bakers are probably very,
very nervous.
This is technically a very difficult
challenge to get right.
The sponge is one element of it, but
they need to bring in other
elements, too.
A mousse, a bavarois,
a jelly, a meringue.
But you've got to get it all working
in unison.
If you've got five, or six, or
seven, or eight different elements,
when you get a mouthful, whatever's
in that spoon must be delicious.
They've got to work backwards.
How long have I got to make this?
How long does it take for the jelly
to set, the sponge to be cool?
It's very, very tricky.
I've been so impressed with those
bakers and I know that they can
all do
incredibly well, so I want every one
of them to be so good that we
struggle to choose a winner.
Hello, Sophie.  Hello, morning.
Hi, Sophie. What are you doing?
I have named mine
The Ode To The Honey Bee.
I just love honey. I find it
fascinating.
I think it's incredible just how
different it can taste.
It's like wine, really.  A tempered
chocolate honeybee and flower will
decorate a marbled white chocolate
mirror glaze entremet,
containing several layers, featuring
honey custard, blackberry jelly,
orange blossom sponge,
hazelnut feuilletine,
lemon curd and a lavender mousse.
Do you think all these things go
together?
I think actually the honey,
and the lemon, and the lavender,
I think it all harmonises
quite well.
I'm trying to think,
lemon and lavender.
I think that could...
I think that will work. Honeybees
like all those things, don't they?
So why shouldn't we?  Let's hope
there's no sting in the tail.
Do you see what he did there?
I'm going to take him away now and
put him in a dark room.
Come with me. Even at the
beginning of this final Showstopper,
the bakers will have to move fast.
I want the whole thing to be
freezing within two and a half
hours.
My countdown timer is everything.
Unless they set their individual
layers quickly,
they won't be firm enough to stack
so they can construct their
entremet.
It's such a process to get
everything chilled.
You can't just stack it all on top
of each other and hope for the best.
What I'm doing here is custard.
This is what I want to get done
first because it's got to freeze.
Got some blackberries, some
sugar and some lemon juice.
I'm just going to mush that down and
make it into a puree.
So, a couple of jobs on the go at
the same time.
This is what we call concurrent
activity and this is an actual
principle of war.
In the battle for the Bake Off
crown...
Multitasking is a principle of war.
..Kate's opened up an Eastern front.
I've coloured my lychee jelly with
red food colouring because the whole
entremet's going to be white and I
really just wanted a flash of colour
in the middle. So that's like the
Japanese flag.
Kate's jelly will sit at the heart
of a Japanese inspired white
chocolate
mirror glazed entremet, decorated
with shards of black sesame tuile,
dragon fruit dice and a tempered
chocolate butterfly.
And all her layers will be encased
in a set custard known as a
bavarois,
flavoured with an oriental twist.
What's that?  Yuzu juice.
Yuzu juice. It's like lemon.
It's like lemon, mixed with
mandarin, yeah.
You look calm.  Do I?
The bake's all about Zen today.
So that's what I'm channelling.
What are you going to do if you win?
If I do, I'm going to do something
ridiculous.
Streak?  Streak!
Through the tent?  I'm going to do a
naked cartwheel.
THEY LAUGH
This is the first layer of custard.
I'll get this freezing.
One thing down, another six to do.
It's the rising sun.
Kate's not the only one headed to
the Far East.
But Steven's given himself twice as
far to travel.
It's a big entremet. It's two
halves.
It'll be a yin yang.
A yin yang is a representation of
light and dark.
And the two can't exist
without one another.
Caramelised bananas with run,
creme brulee, raspberry coulis,
chocolate mousse,
honeycomb feuilletine
and hazelnut genoise
sponge will be
layered in two separate moulds.
And if 14 elements wasn't enough,
the two halves will have contrasting
decoration.
One will be mirror glaze with a
galaxy scene of the Northern Lights
streak. The other half will be
sprayed warm chocolate onto
the frozen
surface, and it leaves what looks
like velvet.
Is this inspired by something?
I was in Sweden when I applied for
the Bake Off.
I remembered the snow on the ground
and you could see the galaxy in the
sky. You saw the Northern Lights.
It was a most beautiful scene.
That's when I applied for the
Bake Off.
You see how inspirational
we Scandinavians are?
Cool, right.
A nice honey set custard.
Usually I'd set overnight.
So I've had to put more gelatine in
than I'd want to.
Rather than setting one layer at a
time, with so much to get through,
Steven is planning to set three
at once.
A layer of custard and a layer
of banana,
then a layer of custard underneath.
But as well as perfectly set
layers...
That's going back in the freezer.
..the judges will expect contrasting
textures.
I'm starting the genoise now. This
is going to be the sponge element.
I picked genoise because it's light
and airy, but it has structure.
This is for my orange sponge.
It's a financier recipe, which is
like a little petit four.
It's almost got a chewy texture.
It's going to be right at the
bottom.
I'm using this pan to just get it as
flat as I can.
When you're stacking, everything is
a little bit out.
There is a cumulative effect.
I'm going to cut it into a circle so
it doesn't need to be neat around
the edges or anything like that.
It's going to go in the oven.
This is the last layer of custard
going on top of the bananas and
we're going to do a final freeze to
get it solid.
I knew this would take a while, but
it is the star of the show.
Right.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
You've got two and a half hours
left,
and then Blue Eyes comes in
and destroys us all.
Lemon curd.  As well as their set and
sponge layers...
Right, what now?  ..all the finalists
are hoping to deliver an element of
crunch.  This is the coconut
dacquoise.
Essentially it's like a meringue
with coconuts.
I'm making a bunch of honeycomb and
I'm going to crush that up and it's
going to go in between chocolates.
My feuilletine layer is basically
like a really
posh Rice Krispies cake.
It's like the Honey Monster's heart.
It's nice, isn't it? I'm just going
to look at this for a bit.
It's making me sort of wistful.
Yeah. Nice and springy.
Look at that.
This is the frozen inserts.
I want to get it cut so I can get
it back into the freezer,
just to give it a little bit more
chilling time.
There you go. Easy does it.
Before they can begin assembling
their final Showstopper,
Sophie, Steven and Kate...
There's so many processes.
..need to perfect a mousse to encase
their entire entremets.
This is a chocolate mousse.
My mousse, it's white chocolate and
lavender.
So, this is the yuzu and white
chocolate bavarois.
It's got a really unique flavour.
It's a bit experimental and that's
what I wanted to do.
Most of the flavours I think,
are terrific.
I think Kate's coconut and yuzu will
be very good together.
They're not too aggressive.
Sophie's gone for the most diverse
flavours I think I've ever heard of
in the Bake Off tent.
Just put the lavender there.
Smell it.  Lavender and lemon.
I initially went really subtle with
it. I'm putting a fair amount in.
I'm a little bit worried about
Steven's.
Chocolate is so dominant.
Has he bitten off more than he can
chew?
Yeah.  He's often come to a point
where timing has been his downfall.
I want all of them to finish what
they set out to do.
Me too.  Is Steven going to finish?
I think Sophie's is very
complicated.
And, actually, is Kate going to be
able to give it the finesse that she
very often lacks?
Just got to give yourself as much
time as possible to concentrate on
the assembly, which is why I'm
trying to fly through these bits.
I'm going to go and retrieve those
inserts.
Hopefully they've set just enough.
Unless they're built quickly...
Everything is just about to set and
I can go ahead.
..there won't be enough remaining
time for the assembled entremets to
set again...  It's all got to be spot
on first-time.
..so that they can be decorated
before the final judging.
It's a bit too sloppy.
Let's get it out. This is the lemon
curd.
I'm going to let it freeze for
another ten minutes, just to reset
everything.
Push the sponge.
Caramelised honey.  I'm trying to use
every single spare second.
It means that I'm prepared for the
next step.
This is the feuilletine.
That is Japan in a cake tin.
This is raspberry coulis going
over the sponges.
Back in the freezer. Just set for as
long as I can.
This is going to set now.
So, I'm going to start doing all my
decorations.
I'm going to start off by doing
honeycomb.
I'm going to use a bit of bubble
wrap.
This is going to be messy. I'm going
to have to do it.
I'm just tipping these into the
moulds.
OK. They're in.  This is cocoa
butter on acetate,
then I'm going to use melted
chocolate on top of this.
Take half the jam with me.
This is going to be my honey bee.
I stuck down little strips of tape
and painted cocoa butter on.
So the chocolate will show through
and he'll have stripes.
Don't know why it's a he.
Well, it is a he, isn't it?
Because only the queens...
Right, my gorgeous finalists.
You've got one hour left.
The entremet needed half an hour
more than it's going to
get in the freezer.
It's got a nice shine on
it, hasn't it?
Come on, come on, freeze, freeze,
freeze.
This is a dragon fruit. It's going
to be decoration for the top.
So soft. I'm worried it's not going
to hold when I take it out the
mould.
STEVEN EXHALES
I have got a chocolate collar.
This is going to be a tuile if it
hopefully works.
Keep calm. Keep the nerves under
control.  Yes.
Here, sweetie.
Thank you so much.
I probably should have done bigger
wings.
I'm going to get it out and have a
look at it.  Is it set enough?
Right, just carry on, carry on.
I've got an entremet, whether it's
a good entremet remains to be seen.
Yes, that's set fine.
I'm going to
work on my mirror glaze.
Let me get this entremet out.
It's holding its shape, I've just
got to be so careful.
It needs to be 30 degrees C.
Bakers, just 15 minutes before the
entire Bake Off of 2017 is over.
It's going to be close,
going to be close.
That is white chocolate and
cocoa butter.
Right, I think I'm going to go
for it.
Right, that's the best you're
going to get out of that.
God, don't inhale cocoa butter.
Moment of truth.
Just make it a bit
more like marble, less squiggly.
Wish me luck.
If I can't present something
beautiful, I'll present what I can.
I've got to add
the chocolate collar.
Oh, no. A bit of a crack.
I need to get it on the cake stand.
Yin needs to meet yang.
It's on.
Not the beautiful entremet
I imagined.
There's cracks all over the place.
Bakers, you have one minute.
Where are me balls?  Come on, Steven.
What's he doing?
What are you doing?
Come on, come on.
Bakers, your final
challenge is over.
Wow.
What a relief.
It's all over. It's all over.
Well done. You did it.
Congratulations.
You got through it.  Well done.
Bless you.
Our kids have all grown up.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
I'm crying now.
Quite beautiful.
Baked our little socks off.
SANDI: Outside the tent, the bakers'
friends and family have arrived,
along with a few familiar faces.
I had butterflies this morning
coming back to the tent,
which is ridiculous,
considering I'm not baking.
It is really amazing to be back.
I've missed everyone so much.
"Hi. How are you?"
It's sort of like a reunion.
If I had to pick a winner, erm...
I'm not going to choose. It'd be
like choosing your favourite child.
They are all fantastic bakers.
I want Stevie to win.
He has taught me so much.
As long as he doesn't do
rubbery jelly, he'll be fine.
..I'd probably say Sophie, you know.
Being a northern lass,
I'd like Katie.
I honestly don't know
who it's going to be.
WHISPERS:  Steven.
HE LAUGHS
NOEL:  It's judgment time for
the final show-stopping entremets.
Sophie, please bring up
your final Showstopper.
Thank you, Sophie. Can you tell us
all about your entremet, please?
So, I've named my entremet
Ode to the Honeybee.
There's an orange-blossom
financier sponge.
Then there is a blackberry jelly.
Then there is a feuilletine
caramelised honey custard,
a set lemon curd...
SHE LAUGHS
..a white chocolate and
lavender mousse and a mirror glaze.
I think the overall look
is absolutely beautiful.
It's original. It's pretty.
The marbling is absolutely stunning.
The colour has broken up
a little bit,
but the honeycomb with the bee,
with the flower,
with the marble, I think,
is exceptional.  Thank you.
Wow. Knife just fell through.
That's great.
Look at that.
That is just set,
and they're not running
into each other, the layers.
Very neat. The jelly, especially.
And it's just holding together.
That is amazing.
Mm! Lemon and lavender
has got to be the new taste.
SHE CHUCKLES
HE SIGHS
I love it.
Being the theme of the entremet
is the honey,
that's the first thing you get,
and it's not overly sweet.
The jelly,
with that little tartness...
The sponge is just right
cos it gives it a little bit of bite
to the whole thing.
And even the lemon
and the lavender work, as well.
Every one of the creamy,
jelly layers
is the right degree of gelatine.
It's not rubbery. It's not liquid.
And on top of all that,
it tastes fantastic.
Thank you.  Thank you.
Thank you so much.
SHE EXHALES
Kate, would you like to bring your
entremet up to the table, please?
Ooh!  Flew off.
Kate, remind us about your entremet.
It's yuzu
and white chocolate bavarois
on top of coconut dacquoise,
with lychee jelly
and a yuzu zest sponge,
and then a yuzu
and white chocolate glaze.
It's tremendously unusual
and beautifully done.
The glaze is as shiny
as a bathroom tile.
The mirror finish you've got
on the top is beautiful
and the colour choices are superb.
Well, that dropped through well,
actually.
Oh, look at that.
They're big and they're bold
and they're equal.
I think that yuzu flavour
is just so sharp and delicious
and surprising.
It starts off
tasting like grapefruit
and then you know it's not
grapefruit. Mm, it's lovely.
I love the flavour combinations.
The bavarois,
it's that light citrus.
Have you put that
in the jelly, as well?
Because it's got this beautiful
citrus hit, as well, in there.
That meringue and coconut
is a little stroke of genius
because it's a different flavour.
It's very harmonious
with the lemony flavours,
and it's drier than the bavarois.
So, you get the contrast of texture
and the contrast of flavour,
and I think
it's really beautiful.  OK.
The jelly melts in the mouth.
Not too much gelatine in there.
The sponge, and then
that light bavarois is sublime.
I'd eat that all day.  Thank you.
Well done.  Thank you.
Well done, Kate.
That's good, mate. Well done.
Good luck, Steve.  Thank you.
Steven, please bring up
your final Showstopper.
Steven, tell us all about
your entremet, please.
So, inside, there is
a hazelnut dacquoise,
genoise sponge
with a raspberry coulis.
There is bananas and custard
surrounded by a chocolate mousse.
On the yin side is
white chocolate flocking,
and on the yang side,
galaxy mirror glaze.
That is extraordinary glazing.
It looks like a shell.
It looks amazing.
The contrast is there, but
I almost want this to be smoother
and a little bit more refined.
This looks a little
as if it's unfinished.
I'm going to go for the mirror.
The distinctive layers
upsets me a little bit.  Mm.
Because this all
comes down to timing,
which I've said before.  Yeah.
The mirror glaze is not quite set,
and so the knife is taking
the colour through
to the next layer,
and the next layer's being pushed
through to the next layer.
Love the bananas.
Love the chocolate mousse.
If I was to close my eyes
and eat that,
that's a chocolate mousse
with a bit of banana in.
You're not getting
too many textures in there.
I want to cut a bit
of the other side
because that blue glaze
is making a muddle.
To me, it's exactly the same.
You've got bleeding
of each of the layers.
It's hard to distinguish any layers
except the dominant ones -
the chocolate and the banana.
It's almost too much
of a good thing.
It's very rich and sweet.
I don't think you'd be able
to eat a lot of it.
I just think
you missed a trick here.
Mm.  I think you missed a trick.
Thank you very much.  Thank you.
Paul and Prue now have
a huge decision to make.
The three bakers came into
the Showstopper pretty even,
so is this a very
difficult decision?
You have elements in all these
which are just sheer perfection.
You have something
exceptional from Sophie.
Sophie's marbling on top
is just amazing.
You have flavours, and the
mirror glaze from Kate is gorgeous.
On the other hand, I'm sure
Steven feels a little bit down,
because I don't think Steven's
is as good as the other two.
Steven's let himself down
a little bit.
Well, ten weeks of amazing memories,
but it comes down to this,
and I do not think
it is an easy decision.
I came in here thinking
I knew who'd win,
and the more I think about it,
I'm going to change my mind.
But I'm not going to tell you who.
Hopefully, you will eventually.
There's a lot of people out there.
And then you can tell them!
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Oh, my God!
SHE LAUGHS
NOEL:  Before the winner is revealed,
Steven, Kate and Sophie
can finally join
their family and friends.
I'm feeling very nervous.
It could go any way.
And I will be incredibly pleased
and proud of them,
especially because
I count Katie and Steven
very much as my friends now.
Genuinely, whoever won,
it would be deserved,
because we've all come so far
from where we started from.
Hey, Mum.
I haven't let go
of that dream of winning.
It left me halfway through the bake.
It left me. But I clawed it back.
Come and sit down. Come on.
I could still win.
HE SIGHS
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Hello. Thank you all for coming.
The moment's here.
I'd like to ask the three finalists
to step forward.
Big round of applause for Kate,
Steven and Sophie.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Come on, then. Come on, lads.
SHE LAUGHS
Good luck.
Right, guys.
I have the huge honour
of announcing...
I'm going to cry!
I have the huge honour
of announcing the winner
of The Great British Bake Off 2017.
You three are amazing,
but I'm afraid there can
only be one champion.
The winner of
The Great British Bake Off 2017
is...
..Sophie.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Well done.
Are you going to cry?
I'm nearly in tears.
Well done, Sophie.  Thank you.
You deserve it, hon.
That's yours, my dear.
You are such a clever girl,
and you deserve it.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
I... I'm sure it'll sink in,
but it hasn't quite yet.
Just kind of disbelief, really.
The idea of winning
is such a minute possibility.
I don't think I'll forget this
for as long as I live.
Well done, Sophie.  Thank you.
Oh, thank you so much, Sandi.
Well done.
I'm going to pinch myself.  Amazing.
Oh, my God.
Can I be honest?
I got a little bit emotional there.
And it's because Sandi got
a little bit emotional.
So, I sort of walked off quite
quickly and went, "It's the wind.
"It's the wind in my eye."
I'm made up for her.
Well done.  Oh, my God.
It's been a real learning curve
for Sophie.
To come up with that entremet
in the final bake, you know, it...
I was really shocked
about the standard.
Sophie seems very calm,
but she's not that confident,
possibly because
she knows everybody else has had
more experience than she has.
Oh, I'm so proud of her. Actually,
I'm really proud of all of them.
You've done well.
This is not the end of you.
I've lost to a really brilliant -
really, really brilliant - baker,
so fair play to the girl.
Oh, Julia.  Well done.  Thanks.
Well done. I'm so proud of you.
I know Sophie
can appear quite tough,
but she's not. She's soft.
Tom.  Well done.  Thanks, buddy.
She was as scared
as Kate and I were,
and for the first time in ten weeks,
I saw vulnerability.
Hello. Thank you so much.
So proud of you.
She's put her heart and soul
into this, as we all have,
but she put her heart and soul
into it and she earned it.
She really earned it.
NOEL:  This is the first time
you've lost your cool.
I'm not really...
I'm going to keep pinching myself.
Baking - I thought it was
almost like a bit of a calling,
so to go from just
that sort of idea,
that sort of initial inspiration...
But I never dared think about it
until we were here.
Met some brilliant people,
and then I got to the final,
and now I'm here.
It is beyond anything
I thought or dreamed of.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
What a privilege.  Well done, Soph.
Yeah, it's pretty mega.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Are you a Star Baker in the making?
If you'd like to apply for the
next series of Bake Off, visit...
Subtitles by Ericsson